a craftsman prepares to carve he starts
by using a masonry compass and a liquid
called Chinese ink to draw the mortars
inner and outer circumference he can
easily remove the ink if there are any
errors he roughs out the shape with a
hammer and chisel he then works with the
grinder which is equipped with an
extremely hard diamond-tipped blade
making it possible to cut through solid
stone
once he's defined the outside edge he
begins to work the inner bowl carving
out the perimeter before cutting a grid
[Music]
he turns again to his hammers and
chisels to remove material from the
inside of the mortar with the grinder he
works away at all of the surfaces
smoothing them to a consistent finish a
mortar isn't much good without a pestle
once again working with the confident
swiftness of an expert the artisan uses
his grinder to hone a chunk of granite
down to the shape of a well-balanced
pestle wide and blunt on one end and
narrow enough to easily grasp on the
other the stone is perfectly calibrated
to do its job in the days before power
tools it would have taken a craftsman a
full day to carve a mortar and pestle
[Music]
but a carved mortar and pestle isn't
necessarily a finished one here
a painter adds the final touches using a
small brush and special varnish he
paints a lotus flower design on the lip
of the mortar he leaves the bowl itself
untouched so that no food products will
mix with the varnish when crushed
[Music]
he then varnishes the exterior of the
mortar the varnishing process is purely
decorative hard stone like granite needs
no protective coating to help it endure
after all some granite has been around
for millions of years it takes just 15
to 20 minutes for the varnish to dry and
with that the mortar is completely
finished the lotus flower design isn't
the only one available
this facility produces a wide range of
mortars and pestles these mortars and
pestles may be attractive but their
appearance is secondary to their
function there are a few tools in a
kitchen more durable or more useful than
a good mortar and pestle
[Music]